i've had a massive shift in how i view
business
and it has fundamentally transformed
everything that i'm doing
[Music]
hi my name's alex for mozy um i own a
portfolio of companies that has 85
million
a year in revenue i have absolutely
nothing to sell you and this is purely
because i just want to help
more people not be broke so that's the
goal all right so one of the things i'm
going to tell you two stories
that significantly changed my uh career
all right hopefully you'll be able to
you'll be able to take the
the message from the story because i
think they're they're really really good
so when i was just starting out in my
gym launch business
i had a gym owner who said hey let's
partner on this like you keep filling
these gyms up in full capacity why don't
you just fill them and i'll come behind
you
and operate them and i had a gym that
was doing 4.2 million a year
this is what he was telling me and i
really know how to operate the business
you know all the acquisition stuff so
let's just partner up on this and i said
sure sounds fair enough it ended up
being a horrible partnership but that's
not the point of the video the point is
what i learned
all right and so we had two locations
and the newest location
had a whole new staff and they were just
lackadaisical right they weren't they
weren't
they weren't caring they weren't really
doing a good job
and he said you know we need to we need
to you know have a meeting and i was
like okay and so he said we'll have a
meeting at the first location
call everyone there tell them to show up
at four o'clock and the
first location was probably like 45
minutes away from the second location
right
and at four o'clock so everyone's
everyone's everyone's coming in
everyone's sitting down it's kind of
awkward it's silent there's clearly like
some tension right
and so at four o'clock he looks at uh
his assistant he says hey go down to the
front
um lock the door right of the gym and
she was like
okay so she goes and locks the door mind
you some people hadn't shown up to the
meeting yet right they were a couple
minutes late whatever
and so all of a sudden as they lock the
door like 30 seconds later someone's
like banging on the door and it's like
hey
open the door and he's like ignore him
and and they were like
like why aren't you letting me in
because obviously there's a meeting
going on right and then another person
comes knocks on the door another person
comes knocks on the door
now there's like three or four people
and they're like what the hell like why
aren't you opening the door or whatever
right and so he tells
uh his assistant he says go outside and
tell him they're all fired and he says
this before he starts the meeting and so
i'm sitting there
right and everyone in the room is like
oh [ __ ]
right he just set the
tone all right and he reset the bar
and i remember witnessing this and being
like wow so what he did was he reset the
bar of this is how we perform when we
say we're going to be somewhere we're
going to be somewhere at that time if we
say we're going to clean up after the
session we're going to clean up after
the session
if we say we're going to follow up with
leads we follow up with leads and what i
have figured
and i'm going to tell you one more story
and then we'll tell you the moral both
of them all right so pause on that for a
second
now when i had my first job i was a uh
actually i think it was my first
it was my first job i was a blender
tender at smoothie king all right
and so um i learned a lot about what to
do and what not to do when i was in this
business it was a small business owner i
think he had two locations to three
locations at the time his name was dave
really nice guy what's up dave and i was
trained personally by dave so dave
trained me
and i was you know enterprising young
man i wanted to do a good job and so i
showed
my first day at work um at one of his
newer locations you know after
you know between people walking in you
were supposed to like mop the floor
clean the counters like just
clean it just make it look good restock
the shelves and so i started doing that
when someone walked out the door it's my
first shift right
and the manager was like what are you
doing i was like i thought like i was
worried i was in trouble so i was like i
thought i was supposed to i'm not
supposed to restock the shelves like i
thought i was supposed to do that right
now because like there's no one here
and he was like oh yeah you don't need
to worry about that he's like we don't
do any of that stuff
and i was like oh okay boom new cultural
norm
all right so what i was supposed to do
and what the owner had trained me to do
and then was always complaining about
how no one ever did what was supposed to
do
the manager was telling me that i didn't
need to do that stuff what i learned
from this
right and i'll just call that manager
john right actually i'll call it manager
vince this is the name i'll use
so i said so do you in your business
have events are you the vince in your
business
do you have someone in your in your
business that's the vince that's
secretly destroying your business
all right so let's rewind to the the
original story about the first homeowner
that was talking about
so think about the difference between
both of those styles of management i'm
not saying the first is right or the
seconds right whatever well
the second one is definitely wrong right
but when you look at that
what it was was setting the tone
and the reason that my views on business
have dramatically shifted is that i have
always had a tendency
to lean towards strategy acquisition
monetization pricing structures and all
that stuff is important
but i think within a business there are
two components to it you've got the
smarts
and you've got the hearts and you have
to have both
and i think that most people
overestimate the importance of smarts
myself included
and i think that there's a lot to do
with the hearts because
business strategy overarchingly is not
that complex like you really think about
it right it's like
you got to find something that's good
that people want and you sell it for a
lot more than it costs you to do it
and you do as much of that as you
possibly can like that's kind of the
idea right
and the thing is is it gets lost in the
execution it gets lost in the doing
right as soon as you hire first
employees you're like no employees can't
boys can't do what i can do it's like
well that's a horrible belief you should
probably change that before you try and
move forward that's a limiting belief
right
if you want to have a big business and
so when i think about this from a
cultural standpoint and this is what has
shifted for me
is that it's become so much more about
the soft skills
it's so much more about coaching and
developing the leaders
of the company it's it's so much more
about addressing behavioral dynamics of
someone that are limiting them
more so than it is about tinkering and i
can't help
but think that so many entrepreneurs
myself included i spent so much time
tinkering and and tweaking things what
if we change this in our sales process
what if we
change this on this page what if we
change the offer like this what would
you change this on the price what if
the payment turns blah blah blah all
these different things right and think
about this for a second for yourself
how many things have you tinkered with
in your business over the last however
many years how many months
and your business hasn't changed at all
right
because the real problem is not the
strategy the problem is not the smarts
right the problem is the heart right the
people are not doing what you want them
to do because they don't understand why
they need to do it and why it's
important
right and that's the soft stuff and
you've got you know people who don't
want to talk to each other because they
don't like each other because one guy's
really annoying
and so it's like it would be it would
better serve you to fix that problem
than to try and come up with some new
strategy right realizing that has been
one of the biggest breakthroughs that
i've had in my career
those two stories should illustrate the
difference between having a championship
mentality
um and having a loser mentality and what
might be going on in your business and
i'll leave you with one more story
really quickly
so if any of you has ever been on a
championship team
right if you've ever played in a sports
uh arena or whatever
and you've been on a winning team you've
been a losing team right and you've
probably been on a losing than a lot of
good players but you guys were not
connected you weren't concerted you
weren't aligned right on the flip side
you had a winning team and it was like
everyone showed up to practice
everyone you know tried their hardest it
was the effort and the consistency and
the alignment of the team that
accomplished the goal the rules were the
same everyone was trying to do the exact
same thing
and so when you think about the entire
business landscape right
your competitors have access more or
less to the same
talent pool that you do they can see
what your strategy is overall and most
people are not that dumb
right and so as long as you have a
relatively sound strategy like you're
not selling things at a loss
right then the difference between the
two is going to be your ability to
execute and have people execute on your
behalf
and so that's going to come down like
for us as ceos we do shift towards
becoming championship team coaches
which is why john wouldn't if he had run
a business would have had a championship
business
because he focused on the fundamentals
and one of my favorite sayings of all
time is
advanced people never don't do the
basics advanced people
never don't do the basics i would go to
i would go to these stages and i would
watch guys get on stage
and they'd say you know we we follow up
with all of our leads you know
within five minutes you know when we get
on sales calls we always ask them why
they're there we label them a problem
you know we overview some of the
passings they've done and then they they
follow a clear framework then as soon as
someone buys we you know we have a good
onboarding process
and nothing they say is revolutionary
it's just that they actually do it and
the people are actually on their behalf
they're not the vince or don't have a
manager like vince who's telling them
they don't that they shouldn't have to
do that work right who's
sabotaging the business what they did is
they set the tone
and then they carry the bar and so their
job is to be intolerant of anything but
excellence and to reinforce that in the
culture so that it's consistently
executed across the company
because that between two companies with
the same strategy
will make the difference between
somebody who yields disproportionate
returns on advertising
crazy profits good growth great
retention on employees low turnover
from a company that doesn't have that
right even though they both have the
same strategy even
if the smaller company has the better
strategy this guy will win and this has
been one of the most profound shifts
that i've had
as a ceo now owner of companies is what
i'm looking for is i'm looking for just
as much soft if not more
soft skills interpersonal dynamics
self-awareness
then i look for skill um
in particular you know like this guy's
really going to finance it's a really
good product this person's really good
at
marketing sales like i'm looking way
more for character traits now
and now that i think about it when you
if you're thinking about yourself
right then i would look in the mirror
and say like am i really are we always
doing the basics
because if we always do the basics we
will be advanced
because that is what advanced people do
is they never don't do them and they
have a culture that reinforces that
standard
so i hope you enjoyed the first story
hope you enjoyed the vint story make
sure you don't have any vince's in your
business
uh my name is alex mosey on portfolio
companies like i said earlier that does
85 million in revenue i have absolutely
nothing to sell you lots of broke people
in this channel to make sure that you
are not one of them
keeping awesome click subscribe and i'll
see you next video bye